well it looks like Marvel Studios is
actually going to do right by the
mutants in the MCU at least that is what
is being reported now many people know
about the firing of Jonathan major as
king the Conqueror in the MCU Jonathan
major is no longer playing Kang the
Conqueror they will recast King
eventually but for now he is being put
on the sidelines until Avengers Secret
Wars or a movie that would come out
right before Avengers Secret Wars now
this whole situation was truly
unfortunate however something positive
kind of came out of it and that is the
inclusion of more X-Men in the
Multiverse Saga as it stands right now
according to reports from some insiders
Marvel Studios is looking to make not
one but two X-Men films and possibly a
Disney plus series about some X-Men
characters as well and based off of what
we've heard it sounds like it's going to
be a pretty decent plan and you have to
remember Kevin fige the president of
Marvel Studios knows a lot about the
X-Men about mutants he started his
career with the very first X-Men film in
2000 from there he went on to work on x2
X-Men the Last Stand and of course a ton
of movies in between like Spider-Man
Spider-Man 2 Spider-Man 3 the Fantastic
4 man thing Punisher Daredevil you get
it Kevin fige has been planning to use
the X-Men in the MCU long before he even
had the right to do it so we know he has
some plans and recently we heard that
Marvel Studios has begun meeting with
writers for upcoming X-Men projects and
with k being sidelined in the MCU Kevin
fagy needs something else to bring a lot
of excitement to the MCU right now
that's also going to hold great
importance to the story and it looks
like he's found that in the X-Men we'll
break down everything you need to know
about these three projects that have
been reported in this video and if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest MCU
news and if you leave a comment and
subscribe you're automatically entered
in our giveaway for chance to win an
Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends
items or some DC items the winner picks
one item and we pick a winner at the end
of each each month only 4 days left so
be sure to subscribe so right off the
bat like I mentioned there are going to
be two separate X-Men movies that Kevin
fuggy wants to make one according to
Insider Daniel rpk will be an X-Men
reboot for the MCU and for now Magneto
is not a part of the plan for that movie
now we'll get back to this movie in just
a bit but it looks like Magneto is not a
part of that plan because and according
to Daniel rpk again Kevin fuge is
looking to make a brother hood of
mutants movie where Magneto will debut
and I personally think that this is a
good idea and I think it's a good idea
because of the group and the story that
comes with the group because the
Brotherhood of mutants is devoted to
mutant superiority over normal humans
which means we are going to be getting
that storyline in the MCU and mutants
and humans coexisting has always been
one of the major story plots for X-Men
and this is something that a lot of
people were really curious about because
everybody is wondering do the X-Men
already exist in R 616 universe and if
so where have they been this entire time
there's plenty of theories that we'll
dive into in another video like Charles
Xavier has been shielding the mutants
from the human population with his
powers maybe with the help of Gan gray
and cerebra again a lot of theories out
there but unfortunately this question
won't be answered until we get our first
X-Men film but keep this in mind about
these two X-Men films Grace Randol
reported that the Fantastic Four film
that is coming to the end MCU not too
long from now is going to take place in
Another Universe this does make sense we
are in the Multiverse Saga and it would
make sense to show us the perspective of
a different Universe than ours we also
know that the Multiverse is going to
start to fall apart incursions are going
to start to happen and universes are
going to start colliding with each other
so even if characters are from a
different Universe there is still great
possibilities for them to interact with
characters from our universe so this
could happen with the X-Men movies as
well they don't necessarily have to take
place in our specific universe but at
the end of everything after Secret Wars
we know there's going to be a reboot and
the new universe will most likely be a
collection of remains from many
different universes and that includes
people as well so even though these
characters might be introduced in other
universes it doesn't mean that moving
forward they won't be in our universe
because they most likely will because
keep in mind we are talking about new
X-Men not the old X-Men those are going
to return in Deadpool 3 and Avengers
Secret Wars but this is a new X-Men team
and a new Brotherhood of mutants team
and I really like the idea of building
up separately an X-Men team and a
Brotherhood of mutants team that gives
us more time and it's not as rushed and
it gives us time to get more invested in
these characters that way when they do
finally meet we care more we care more
about the X-Men and we care more about
Magneto and his cause this is kind of
been one of Marvel's problems lately
they tend to rush everything and not
give us enough time to really get in
invested in certain characters and care
about certain characters so having a
movie that focuses on the X-Men talks
about their story how they come together
or came together if they're already a
team giving them a different X-Men
villain or just simply Marvel villain to
take on in that movie and then do a
movie about Magneto talk about his past
talk about some of the past of other
villains that are joining him and then
finally have them come together in a
different movie where the X-Men go up
against the Brotherhood I think that
would be awesome and it certainly would
get people super excited about the MCU
again which is exactly what Kevin fige
wants and needs so we could be getting a
Brotherhood of mutants film where
Magneto will be the main character of
that film and we could be getting a
separate X-Men film which hopefully will
show how the X-Men came together how
Professor X got his X-Men team and like
I mentioned if they do make a Disney
Plus show about the X-Men this will
probably play a big role for these two
Mutant movies because if they release
the Disney plus series before and they
choose to make one episode about one
specific X-Men character well then one
that'll give us enough time to invest in
these individual characters like I
mentioned before but two it'll also make
it to where the movies don't seem that
rushed because the characters that are
going to make up the X-Men team or the
Brotherhood of mutants team will have
already been shown to us we will already
have known a little bit about them
already so overall it will probably feel
a lot more complete and I do like the
idea of a Disney Plus show about the
X-Men or mutants having one episode
dedicated to one or two specific mutants
rather than having a show that starts
with a story and just progresses all the
way on it'll kind of be like Marvel's
what if where each episode is about a
specific story about specific characters
that's how they can do this for the
X-Men and if the goal really is to make
two separate X-Men movies one about the
good guys and one about the bad guys it
definitely would be cool to have gotten
to know some of these mut
before we dive into these movies and
this is what Marvel Studios was planning
before with their special presentations
we heard that they were going to make
some special presentations about Nova
Ghost Rider the Silver Surfer and side
note some of these are still being
planned by Marvel Studios According to
some insiders but the reason that Marvel
Studios wanted to do these special
presentations about these characters was
so you had a little bit of context for
their story before they're introduced in
another film and it's kind of a perfect
idea for an X-Men film where a lot of
different people are involved a lot of
different mutants would be introduced
into movies let's say we have an X-Men
team of six characters and then we have
a Brotherhood team of six characters as
well it's totally possible to do movies
with these characters and kind of give
us some quick backstories about them of
course this is what we've seen done in
the past and it's worked in the past
however if we have a little bit more
understanding of what their stories are
we'll definitely be more invested and
will care more about the characters
which is what I really think has been
missing from Marvel Studios recently so
I hope these reports end up being true I
hope Marvel Studios decides to make not
only these two films but a Disney Plus
show as well and I do like not
introducing Magneto in the first X-Men
movie but giving him his own specific
movie and giving his team their own
specific movie as well but go ahead and
let me know your thoughts about this in
the comments down below and if you have
a specific X-Men lineup in your mind of
who you would like to see debut be sure
to put that in the comments down below
as well please don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you can stay up
to date on the MCU you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof